today's talk is going to be a little bit
about
you know i'll give you a little bit of
context on why i talk about this topic
so i've been in the off space for quite
a bit we didn't used to call it mlaps at
all
um but it's interesting so there's a
community online called the analogues
community um i think i was like one of
the first hundred people in it and like
this discussion around like is it devops
for ml is ml ops devops formal is it is
it not like it's it's literally been
going on for years
and so what i figured i'd do is kind of
talk a little bit about the process what
we're seeing how we're building the
software
uh and uh get let you decide on kind of
like why
i think
mlaps is so interesting and what it
encompasses
so a little bit of context real quick so
my name is diego oppenheimer i'm an
executive vice president at the robot i
run most of the mlaps teams there before
that i was the ceo and founder of a
company called algorithmia
we got acquired about seven months ago
and before that i actually built some of
the
largest bi products at microsoft
including power bi excel sql server so
i've been in this data space for for
quite a bit and kind of seen the
evolution of the different tooling and
how it happens
and i see a lot of similarities
you know it's same but different same
but different so that's where the half
truths come from
so
there's this always this question right
how do i display this model how hard can
it really be i mean anybody can grab a
container and build a flask app and put
an api right like
everybody can do that it takes me like
you know two minutes reading a blog post
on how to do that i can do it at my
laptop i can get out to it but the
reality is is that as soon as we
actually start thinking about real life
use cases things that have any sort of
operational rigor any sort of
repeatability anything that we actually
need to scale um this becomes a lot more
complicated and
deploying software is not a new thing so
you know where is this coming from and
how do we actually thinking about it
so if you remember and he just left so
that sucks because all i wanted him to
do is remember this slide
um but the the core of it is look the
one thing i want you to remember about
today is that machine learning and
production machine learning are
completely different things and this is
really at the core of you have to think
about and there's a lot of processes a
lot of architecture a lot of concerns a
lot of organizational issues that you're
going to think about which just makes
these things completely different and so
again if you remember one thing before
you leave today is just that title and
then i'll be happy
so
devops is this set of practices right
it's intended to reduce the time between
committing a change to a system and the
chain being placed into production so
there's a philosophy around devops right
it's around iteration it's around
responsiveness it's around actual going
through quick iterations and being
successful at it
and when we start thinking about the
principles of devops and the tooling
behind devops and we start thinking
about well
the software of the future is going to
be powered by machine learning
right does anybody here disagree with
that
okay good
hopefully uh and so
when we start thinking about it's like
okay well so then the devops of the
future will have to take into
consideration
right the concepts behind machine
learning what we care about what the you
know how data is used and the
differences and at the core of it this
is like the really most important thing
is the core is that we're changing
between deterministic code and
probabilistic code
right that's the the core principle of
the difference right we are now dealing
with probabilistic code versus
deterministic code and that actually
makes us think that it's hey maybe
there's principles maybe there's things
that we can repeat but it might actually
be different
so
we've conducted this is algorithmia i
say we still like before we got acquired
we used to conduct this uh this survey
surveyed over 500 data scientists
machine learning engineers vps of data
science and you've probably seen the
stat slice and diced in a middle in
different ways but the reality here is
most data science teams most ml teams
spend
way more time on infrastructure
on building out the infrastructure on
coney and getting permissions on getting
the data access and preparing it then
they actually do on any sort of modeling
task right and if you go think about
well where the value is well it is in
those modeling tasks and iterating over
those modern tasks so how can we
actually break down those problems and
say hey where are the pieces that we can
actually automate what are the pieces
that we can get out of the way so that
we can actually stick to the thing that
brings the most value that we as data
scientists and data engineers can
actually say hey this is actually how
we're going to go make you know a value
out of this technology
so
i'm going to try to run like a just
quick comparison between what a
traditional software development life
cycle is and then what the machine
learning life cycle is and so you can
kind of start seeing where the
you know kind of differences but also
kind of like where the similarities can
be and what we can borrow so i'm big on
borrowing from the past here because we
actually can implement methodologies we
can implement organizational structures
and we can implement philosophies
so that we can actually build
a ml powered software faster
more iteratively and at a larger scale
so in the traditional software life
cycle you know we got git our service
control
we might have our ci and continuous
integration pipelines our jenkins or git
lab we might have our continuous
deployment which will be you know
whatever aws heroku and we might have
our management stack where we're like
you know prometheus or elk stacks
whatever it is what we're using for
observability
so now we go into
the machine learning lifecycle i'm glad
to say you can use git or git like
functionality i think this uh if i would
have this talk five years ago uh i would
still get the weird eyes and be like
really we're gonna use git for data
science
um you know we have our test sets
we have our uh you know general kind of
like how we're actually gonna go run
these deployments on gpus or cpus
how we're going to deal with those cold
starts and then we have that continuous
evaluation life cycle so you can see
like we have the stages right in terms
of how we build we train we deploy the
question really comes in where the big
difference is is the speed of iteration
the speed of iteration at which machine
learning actually goes through that life
cycle is at least 10 times faster than
what we go through in the software side
of things and that's when things start
breaking right because at this point
it's that iteration speed and we're
gonna talk a lot about iteration speed
today
so how is this all different it's a
continuous life cycle right so we go
through the development we build our
models we train our models we get new
data we now deploy those models scale
them up down then we actually have to
understand you know hey wanted to go
down what's our sla how do we manage
these components so
not only is the ecosystem and the
tooling i mean i think there was two
days here packed with new tools on how
to do every single piece of the
ecosystem um but you know we're actually
seeing this this life cycle that moves
so much faster than the traditional way
that we actually iterate through
software um and then how do we actually
do upgrade i was like how do you upgrade
your your machine learning model right
well you're actually upgrading it
consistently
right like so obviously the the mecha is
this continuous ai the continuous
retraining but the reality is is we're
updating models we're updating data sets
we're updating components in these uh
pipelines all the time
and that adds complexity anybody who's
here with this quick show of hands who's
actually operated a you know actual like
operational system something that's like
real time
running that you know your pager who's
wearing a pager here
there you go okay so
if it's not broken you don't touch it
right
like that's kind of like a core
principle of it right it's like if i'm
wearing a pager i don't want to touch it
because if it breaks the problem so
every single upgrade every single change
is like something that gives you a
little bit of a heart palpitation well
imagine if that should be happening
every minute every hour
right and so this is kind of like where
you start preparing your processes and
your people to actually adopt to it
so one of the things that
um
i like being a little bit more
interactive does anybody know what boys
lot of iteration is
okay great cool awesome i get to teach
something then so uh so this is actually
from like 1980 so boys law was a corner
in the air force who was actually
studying um
dog fighting
right and so he was actually observing
the dog fights between migs and f-86s
right and what he came to the conclusion
is that the speed of iteration beats the
quality of iteration every single time
so if a pilot could actually make his
decision process faster he could
actually go through observe understand
where his enemy was shoot and just move
quick just quickly iterate through that
process
eight out of ten times would beat his
opponent in a dogfight and this is after
studying times with and you can actually
see
the studying of that dog fighting and
that exact same principle actually
repeats itself in sports training it
repeats itself in software engineering
through agile development and we see it
also in software testing and so at the
core of it iteration speed beats the
quality of every iteration
and so how fast we can move through the
system becomes core to how the the
quality of that actually system overall
and that doesn't change in the world of
machine learning except now we can
iterate even faster so when in doubt
iterate faster
and think about that entire workflow
that you're going through and how
quickly you can move through it
so
this is what
a stack for machine learning looks like
today
right you obviously don't need all the
components but you have your notebooks
you have your core repos you have your
data engineering and orchestration
layers you have your data sources your
data engineering engine sometimes you
have labeling if you're working with
instructor data you have your
experimentation engines
you have your training engines you have
your inference engines and deployment
you have the monitoring you have your
feature stores for certain use cases you
have to put this all in a data
infrastructure
so when you start thinking about
iteration like this is the workflow
that your iteration has to work through
right
there's a bunch of tools that you need
to combine that need to work in an
ecosystem and they need to go through
this process as quickly as possible
again
speed of iteration beats quality of
iteration every single time
so
probably not something that is uh you
know crazy control here but it is data
is useless without algorithms
and
the
you know but algorithms are also useless
without data so you actually have to be
able to feed in between these two things
at any given time to be able to uh you
know work with it together so we're
going to walk through the process and
i'm going to talk about some of the
technical challenges of this iteration
life cycle and then i'm going to talk
about some of the organizational and
people challenges
through this iteration life cycle
because both of them and again if you go
look at
devops devops is not tooling it's a
philosophy
that has tooling
right but at the end of the day the
philosophy behind is really what the
core is we we decide to become iterative
through software responsive and agile to
build software faster well guess this is
the same way for actually building
machine learning systems
so at the core of it
training
and production
systems are really really different
architecturally
so if you think about a training job
it's usually
a lot of compute for a long compute
cycle it's usually stateful hopefully
right you're checkpointing you're
understanding you're going through your
training job it's exploratory
and in most cases it's single user i say
it's single user because it's pretty
rare to see multiple people
collaborating on one training job
right it's like you some you know
somebody clicks the button they go run
the train and there might be multiple
but that's really at the core of it
when you're thinking about production
you know it's usually short
intense compute bursts right you're
making a prediction
right and whatever that prediction is
needed whatever that pipeline is it's
usually a short intense compute burst
um you need it to be elastic
and the reason why you need to be
elastic most cases right is because you
have a one-to-many relationship right so
if you think about every single one of
your cell phones hitting a recommender
system at the same time right because of
your app on your phone you know that's
what you're looking at right it's a
one-to-many relationship there
so it's usually stateless
you know my prediction is irrelevant for
his prediction and his prediction and
it's usually as i said the one-to-many
relationship so at the core you have two
from a computational layer like very
very different architectures
that you need to address for this
automation in between the two parts
so
how do i actually you know bridge that
gap between training and production
so you know i talk usually about you
know my suggestion is to use this kind
of two git flow
right where you know machine learning as
i said um
unlike some of the kind of more common
traditional software actually
most times has completely distinct code
bases
so you know what i said hey it's same
but different right like it is not
normal that the model when i build in
software in traditional engineering my
app i have it in tests and when i deploy
is completely different that's just not
the case but
training code and inference code are
by definition very very different and
they behave in different ways
um and so we people have that one repo
for training and that one repo for uh
you know for inference is one way of
splitting this technically in terms of
understanding but you know then actually
being able to tie those two things
together
so when you're actually going to do a
deploy you know how do i easily package
deploy but still be able to checkpoint
and understand where that where that
inference is coming from
so then we have new challenges right
which is
we have new hardware
right and uh i don't know how many of
you have like had the pleasure of uh you
know working extensively with gpus uh
but until recently like you ran out of
memory on one and they blow up on you
and you have to restart it and it's like
i mean it's not
it's not cpus right i don't have the
controls of cpus that have you had over
like the last 30 years
it's you know nvidia's made it a lot
better i have to admit that um but you
know it's still kind of the wild west
how do you control these machines how do
you control this and then you still have
to adapt it different chipsets different
libraries what i'm training on i might
be using a certain chipset from you know
on a gpu i might be using a completely
different chipset on uh on my inference
how do i actually reconcile these
differences so the complexity between
these two sides of the house only
increases
and then we have
the beauty of containers right
where and this is my amazing graphic
designer on a shared kernel by the way
um so this is why i'm not in marketing
uh the
uh so
you know what happens when i have a
completely you know one framework and
one side of the container have a
completely different one they're sharing
the same kernel they're interacting with
it like dealing with these things from
an operational perspective is highly
complex and understanding that like
these things change so going back to
that first you know hey i'm just going
to deploy a model you can see how this
complexity increases over time
and then we actually get to the point
where hey we actually are going to have
completely heterogeneous tools and
dependencies so if you remember
and by the way i actually do recommend
like
in my opinion the best architected
systems are ones that are tightly
integrated and loosely coupled
right so i can actually grab
best-in-class components to build out my
architecture
and i can pop in and out of those and
i'll be able to automatically do it
again iteration speed beats all the time
and so how do i actually deal with the
dozens of languages and frameworks and
combinations how do i actually deal with
all the different hardware dependencies
that i have how do i actually deal with
the different frameworks that emerge
every year and i need to integrate into
them and so this is again why you start
thinking about your production
environment and your training
environments as two separate uh
components at least so that you can
actually start adopting and automating
through those
two at baseline
and then you have to start pipelining
right so really
a model doesn't live in isolation you
know i usually have a use case and that
use case is a pipeline of pre-processing
and post-processing and splits and
classifications and i need to be able to
coordinate through each one of those
steps in an automated way and so now i
have here and i'm just a random example
where i have scanned documents and maybe
i do some ocr on it and i get it ocr is
not machine learning i'm just trying to
show an example of an of a pipeline here
you know language identification text
vectorization some sentiment analysis
so
what if i need to change any of these
components right how do i when i talk
about that iteration speed
if i actually have to go manage
every single one of these components
independently and see what change what
dependencies change where those can this
is where this automation this is where
this philosophy around devops and that
around being able to think about the
entire system and put and this is where
at the core i believe mlaps is right
which is that automation
tracking auditability governance of the
entire way you're building your
pipelines becomes core because at any
point any of these things can go
south
you're iterating faster on any of these
components than you ever have on any
other piece of software
so then we actually have the model
performance right and so this is
obviously like particularly important so
what does performance mean
in the application world well an
application where it might be an sla it
might mean that i'm actually being able
to scale you know horizontally like to
be able to take the request well
performance in the world of machine
learning has a bunch of different
meanings right
am i losing accuracy
is my data is drifting is my composite
drifting what am i actually you know
it's also slas so now you have this
definition of performance that has
multiple different vectors around it
that you also need to be like monitoring
for so this is why those monitoring
tools and those
are are also same but different
right so there's a reason why we don't
just you know slap uh you know a data
dog onto your machine learning model you
can you can write a bunch of code but
you know there's a reason why these
specialized tools are coming in to be
able to actually look through
that you know the monitoring components
of of performance for these individual
models as that uh you know
statistical code is actually being run
so where are the tests
right so again like this reason like if
we're gonna actually be moving this
quick
right
how do we put safeguards in it
like unit testing
for ml
i like that
anybody write unit tests for their
machine learning models
i only got one that's actually
impressive like i've actually asked this
question this is the first time i
actually got one hand uh but it's
absolutely possible right so as you
think about you're thinking about this
to get workflow and you're actually
checking in new inference code you can
actually write unit tests actually go
check baseline
for those models as they get quite
compressed and deployed and run you can
actually start running smoke tests you
can start running performance tests
those performance tests are not just
about the model accuracy they're also
about that sla about that operational
about the scale up so you can start
thinking about okay well i'm building
these major systems how do i actually
start borrowing again these concepts
from the world of devops and philosophy
of the world so i can increase my
confidence on the iteration speed
because at the core of it this isn't
about tooling it's about increasing
confidence so you can move as fast as
possible
so i usually like use this really really
corny phrase so you're gonna have to
deal with me but as like i say like the
path between
you know training and production today
and machine learning is a dirt road you
want to build the autobahn
right why do you want to build the
autobahn because the autobahn you feel
confident that you can
go as fast as you want on that right and
you're you know if you go as fast as you
want on a dirt road you are going to
skid out
but also the autobahn has controls it
has rails it has pavement there is
actually police that are looking at
there is toll roads right and so the gov
you know the governance to control
everything around the system is giving
you the confidence to move through that
system a lot faster
so this goes to that point right which
is around audit audibility and
governance how do i go call out and say
who called what when with what data and
why
i want to be able to go back and replay
that
that audibility and confidence first of
all it's crucial for debugging when
something goes wrong as you have to go
spelunking into what went wrong so you
have to be able to provide those logs
and be able to go back in time and
understand it but also it's a core
component about building confidence on
iteration speed if you know that you
will be able to find what went wrong
you will care less about the quality of
the iteration and more about the speed
of the iteration
and again that is where you want to end
up
so
i think in this crowd i don't actually
have to talk about this but like i
usually have to explain you know what
what model drifting looks like if i all
had images of people in the summer and
that's all i trained my model on and
then suddenly i you know had a winter
picture it probably wouldn't know what
it's looking at right and that's just
the idea that also this is a unique
challenge in the world of machine
learning which is
nothing can change in the code base and
yet everything changes in the system and
so how do we actually think about that
and start applying again apply those
the principles of devops but you can't
just
apply all the principles you can't just
assume it's going to work in the same
way and you can't assume you can use the
same tooling for it
and so introspection is so important
around this right and so everything from
monitoring to logging to alerting to
observability so hey who gets called so
i got a couple of hands on the pagers uh
you know when on that it's very rare to
have a data scientist have a pager
some places do
right but it's really really rare right
so now this concept is our sres
who are running these systems and now
there's this concept of a machine
learning mlre which is a machine
learning reliability engineer who's
actually understanding hey
where do i go look
when some of these systems go wrong
because at the core of you know if we're
actually successful and i believe we are
going to be in making all these systems
be mission critical because the world is
going to run on machine learning and all
software's going to run on it the
reality is is that there's going to be
situations where if something doesn't
get fixed we're going to be
in risk of
reputational damage
you know making decisions or going down
operational damage to the organization
lose a lot of money or not make enough
money whichever one you want to pick of
those
and the on the other side is there's a
risk of not doing anything right if i
don't apply machine learning you better
believe that my competitors will so you
have to do it you have to approach it
and there's also risk so how do you
build those guardrails and that's really
around that introspection so how do you
get the logging the monitoring the
learning and the observability around it
so
at the core of it you know what i talked
about that flask app with an api there's
a little bit more to it
right especially when you're actually
doing it at scale for real-time systems
um and a lot of times it's economically
challenging not for the technology so i
covered all the technology pieces i
think you all understand here that there
is a lot of technology to take into
account but in a lot of cases it's
really about people and what's happening
it so it's a lack of process
it's the wrong incentives from those
organizations it's the wrong teams it's
the wrong technology and then the
critical which is any sort of technology
buy or implementation without the lock
with the lack of proper champions
instead in the water no matter how good
it is
so how do we actually tackle these
problems and this is kind of my
uh you know i like to say it's like
these are the scars of uh
the scars of time that have like how you
know kind of developed how to kind of
tackle these large-scale build out of
systems and and how to do that so
when you're thinking about the stucco of
the lab right and you've probably heard
about it this is not a new concept right
like ah machine learning is stuck in the
lab like nothing gets out no data models
well the core of it is that
there's a cemetery of proof of concepts
in in data science that's not
necessarily a bad thing the only thing
is a bad thing is like the ones that
actually should have gone to production
and didn't
because they were planned incorrectly
anytime you are looking at a data
science project or machine learning
project i do use those interchangeably
even though they can be quite different
um
you need to go look and say okay
how is this going to work in production
that's the first question
where is this going to show up what
system are we going to be running it
because if i don't actually map
backwards i don't care how much time i
spend building the most accurate model
on earth
it's never going to see the light of day
so you have to be able to map your way
all the way back so is this going to be
a recommender that's running on our
website great okay what's the traffic of
that website how we're gonna deploy it
how are we gonna actually get it into
that into that front page who's gonna
maintain it who's the sre these are all
things that you wanna know or at least
have a brief map of before you even go
look at the data
and this rarely happens this really
rarely happens
so
you know you have this concept of you
know we train models and we show this
concept but there's no way to it so
the business is just sitting there and
by the way you know as most of you
hopefully know at this point who carries
the purse for hiring more data
scientists more machine learning
engineers bigger investments bigger
tools better tools more compute more
cpus more gpus it's always the business
right because that's the you know one's
a cost center and the other one's not
and so if you can actually show the
results to the business and they don't
care about it they don't really you know
i i do that they don't care if it's a
hundred monkeys coding
like on their own or the best machine
learning system in the world if it
produces the same results it's the same
results
right and so you have to be able to map
how you're going to get those results
you can fund the rest of the journey
so
the disconnected teams is really
interesting so i i think the
this was the really part that was really
telling for me over time was how many
times i would go into it you know help
out
a large enterprise in terms of the
machine learning project
and i would say hey can you invite i'm
meeting with the vp of data science and
data science team and we could talk
about all the concepts in the world and
it's like hey can you invite your it
counterpart
they look at me like
what are you talking about yeah like who
runs i.t here like who provisions the
permissions who's going to give you
access to the databases who's going to
let you like get that aws like you know
launch those like three instances in aws
they're like oh we need to talk to them
like yeah
you're not going to get anything here
done ever and he's like well we'll call
them later and we'll tell them like yeah
that's not how this works
like you're gonna get nowhere so you
need to actually have those you have to
bring in
you know this idea that a data scien an
effective data science team can work in
isolation throw their work over the wall
and have it auto magically show up in
production is a complete fallacy
and if it works it's painful
right and so you have to get into this
world it's like okay who is the right
skill set who are those pager people you
know hopefully
i say this with all the love in the
world but sres are like you know godsend
uh you know but like you know like who
are the people running the the pagers
who are gonna be out like who owns that
production pipeline because if you're
not talking on day one on how you're
actually gonna get through this system
you're never gonna see the light of day
and so you have to start planning around
that how that collaboration is gonna
work what the actual responsibilities
and the accountabilities are between
those teams
so
for you know another law um
which is you know the
you know conway's law kind of talks
about how organizations which design
through the constraints
of their organization will actually like
just copy that communication so if your
team is not talking to the devops
your systems aren't talking either
right and so
you need to understand who the
responsibilities for each component is
going to be
how we're going to actually get those
models built out and again this is as
you can see
i've been talking about
you know emo ops and devops and i'm not
talking about technology anymore like
this is really an organizational change
and a philosophy chains for
effectiveness of actually getting
machine learning teams to scale and
actually being able to get these things
in production
so then we have the technology mismatch
which is
lack of defined technologies or stacks
or best practices
um everybody builds their own thing with
absolutely no repeatability
measurability or auditability so hey i
just got it running somebody else
maintain it you know the lack of hit by
a bus mentality which i know is a really
awful thing to say but
you know you have to plan your systems
that like the person who wrote it will
not be there tomorrow
um
you know you're not thinking about the
access to data you're not thinking about
these differences between production and
development
and so what is the best ml
architecture for my organization it's
something you legitimately need to be
able to answer and it's an iterative
process and you want to design around it
and so
you know you can kind of actually look
through what are the different
components and there's a lot of tooling
out there and the answer is
it depends it depends on your
organization it depends on what your use
cases are but the reality is that you
want to start having an opinion
around a canonical stack
of tools so that you can start taking
advantage of those economies of scale
and so
like with any sort of application having
no stakeholder buy-in
is just a death trap and i'll explain
the situation where this happens more
often than not so i just talked about
hey bring your rit folks
uh you know and bring your people in and
bring all these people to bring all that
well guess what we live in a human world
at some point you're gonna get stuck
at some point you're not gonna get the
access or there's gonna be some rule
that is like you know backwards
something is gonna and a champion
and a champion with authority inside
this ecosystem somebody who cares about
this workflow this application and what
you're doing here becoming seeing the
light of day
will be that person who unblocks
right and so i always tell my teams i
say
hey great that you're talking to the vp
of data science it's great that you're
talking to the vp of i.t
who do they connect with
oh it's a bubble bot okay talk to that
person because at some point you're
going to have to call that person and
they're gonna have to unblock between
the two places and that's how you're
gonna actually get your application in
production that's how you actually get
your workflow in production
so how do you get
you know your buy-in from your
stakeholder well
you make it personal what's in it for
them we are you know we're humans right
it's all about you know we can design
systems
where everybody's greedy right we're
looking out for our best interests but
you can actually design systems to find
that to actually be for the greater good
so how do we actually get out of the
lack of process so
you know you want to plan and fund
deployments up front
you want to set clear deployment
criterias again how are we actually
going to get to production what are the
conditions of production
um you want to bring in your
stakeholders really early and you want
to build for repeatability in your
process
and so i did not invent this but it's
actually one of my favorite uh like
devices that i've used in building out
not only large
projects in machine learning but also
teams
um so ian shaw he's a consultant
he knows that i borrow this all the time
i use it i love it so if you know the
concept of mvp from you know the minimum
viable product from product and agile
development i think the concept of in
machine learning is the minimal
justifiable improvement tree what is the
minimal improvement to a process an
optimization or a decision automated
decision making that it's worth the
investment that i'm about to go do in
people technology and time
and the way that you actually break that
down and say well what's the objective
okay if i can actually price a bond
better
right
and i think i can make two million
dollars a year by doing that
is it worth investing four million
dollars to do it
maybe it depends on how many years
right and so you have to start with the
up with that objective which is what is
the improvement i'm going to get to
what is the value that i'm going to see
out of this and understand that on day
one so that i can actually put into
concept the whole rest of the of the pie
in this case it might be okay what's the
business process to getting set through
what are we changing what are we
automating is this a back office
operation that we're actually going to
go touch 300 different systems by
automating it that might be good that
might be bad what's the access look like
so now i can actually start costing
everything in our head around this whole
project again starting from the end
going to the beginning in terms of
okay what are we actually doing with
this and what are we gonna actually get
out of it
you have the organizational you have the
financing the budgeting and then you can
see
that actual technology
is all the way at the bottom
so now i know what the process is going
to look like i know where this is going
to show up i know what the target
optimization or objective looks like now
i'm ready to start looking at the data
that i have do i have the right modeling
techniques can i actually model it do i
have the right technology and what am i
going to go build it
so i just curious here how many people
have started this way versus the other
way around
most people i'm just going to take a
long guess including myself have usually
started bottom up here
on this right oh what's the data i have
let me go see what i have i haven't
really figured out how i'm going to get
all the way through it
so
increasing success
is really about thinking about the
process you can build around this and
actually looking at those objective
functions
so
to kind of start wrapping this up
you know ml is a huge growth phase it's
really difficult and expensive for
devops to keep up
you know you start out with a few models
and a couple of frameworks
and one or two languages
probably python and r you know you start
with the dedicated hardware vm hosting
self-managed devops team hey we can do
it we got this you know you have that
unicorn machine learning engineer who
somehow knows how to do literally
everything
right and she's there and she can grab
data and she can model and she can
deploy and she can use aws and she can
do everything and that's there's like
three of her in the world
you know you have a high time to deploy
you know like around this you have few
end users
um no need to really auto deploy you
know common idea now
i go into the forward and i look at how
this is going to start accumulating
right so i go from
that
few users
right
the dedicated hardware the high time to
deploy everything's manual to well what
happens if suddenly tomorrow
i have 15 more use cases
and you know i think there's only
there's there's a couple of like
definitely true is tomorrow there's
going to be more models in production
than there is today i think that's
not really controversial and so you can
see how they start scaling out you have
to build
for repeatability you have to build for
the iteration you have to build for the
automation there isn't this is not a
manual scale out that can happen inside
an organization and the beauty about
machine learning as a technology is that
it could literally be implemented
anywhere and everywhere so this isn't a
question of like oh this is just in the
software team you're going to be seeing
this in finance you're going to see this
in marketing you're going to be seeing
this in in uh you know in in in
traditional software development it's
everywhere right and so the scale is
going to be like this is the software of
the future so we have to start thinking
about how do you scale that out how do
you automate through it
so
think of the things to consider when
you're building ml systems in enterprise
infrastructure agnostic deployment
what's under you might change
collaboration and pipelining how do i
use components from different parts of
the business how do i actually
collaborate between different parts of
the business
what are the performance slas that are
going to be required for this to be a
real use system in real life
if you are in you know financial
services or life sciences like you
probably have some some level of
regulatory compliance so model risk
management how do you generate the
explainability of these models are
becoming more important how do i
actually do governance and what i mean
by governance is how do i secure if you
think about the traditional i.t
governance which is around security
and auditability and ability to tie
expense to strategy these are all things
that are also important in the world of
ml
accounting
who's paying for it
so in a lot of organizations so this
some of the stuff can be really
expensive compute wise
really really expensive
and so if different parts of the
businesses are using it who's paying the
bill
great so you want to share the bill okay
well if you're sharing the bill how are
you attributing
what's being used for you so you have to
now start thinking about again none of
this is data science machine learning i
know this is not sexy but you got to
pass the bill to somebody right how do
you actually do that accounting of these
pipelines
and then obviously security
authentication so
how do you navigate these pitfalls and
i'll kind of close it out which is don't
reinvent the wheel there's a whole bunch
of
components out there there's a whole
bunch of tooling out there like your job
is to think about
what the full use case looks like how
you're gonna get there and what are the
best tools to get you there
um don't try to be perfect i'll go back
to boy's law right iteration speed will
beat iteration quality every single time
and then
tools are not solutions
and then be honest with yourself right
the tool that you use yesterday might
not be the tool that used tomorrow and
that is okay
you do not need to plan
for the next 10 years
when the software is being improved
every 10 months
if not faster
and so start thinking about okay what
parts of these systems can i pop in can
i pop out what am i going to be using
what is the fastest way to getting that
result
so i asked you to remember one thing
when you started which was that one
slide which is machine learning is not
production machine learning and now you
can see how like really when you're
thinking about production machine
learning a lot of it has nothing to do
with the latest and greatest
you know archive paper
and it has nothing to do with some of
the greatest techniques or the latest
framework that came out it's actually
about thinking how we're actually going
to get to speed and scale on what is
really the most amazing technology that
we're probably going to see in our
lifetime
and that is
all i have for you today
[Applause]